i used to write everything with an oscar
speech planned
uh
and and that oscar speech was more of
who you know it wasn't who i was gonna
think it was who i hated
how did fear of success almost ruin your
writing career
oh fear of success ruins my writing
career every day
it's um
yeah it's there's there's multiple fears
there's fear of success there's fear of
failure
um
and i think i still self-sabotage myself
uh
i have to get into a world of um
it's a weird world of delusion whereas i
know i'm writing the
greatest thing ever
told to man
and through all of human history
except it's also a piece of crap at the
same time
um
so
you know fear i mean i guess there's
there's fear of success and fear of
failure yeah it was
i i used to
i used to write everything with an oscar
speech planned
uh
and and that oscar speech was more of
who you know it wasn't who i was gonna
think it was who i hated and i was just
going to tell i was going to bring all
my resentments out you know and it's
it's uh
it's silly and it's absurd to think
about but it would be fun to do an oscar
speech but then
you kind of look at it and go yeah but
would it be really fun to go to the
oscars
um
but
yeah fear fear of success uh
it's weird because i've had very minor
success i don't i don't have a you know
i don't feel like i have
i feel grateful for the success i've had
but in my very minor success it's
sometimes it's a little disconcerting
uh or um where it's just like oh crap
yeah that's out there for people to see
oh
um
and i forget
and but at the same time that's
wonderful so what a you know what a
bourgeois
problem that is
are you gonna go to starbucks and pay
with two credit cards after this i'm
gonna pay with two credit cards i'm
gonna ask for water and i'm gonna put
ice in it and i'm gonna be like you're
gonna have to take this back and not put
ice on this okay right
yeah um
do you almost feel guilty if things go
well for you
what yes oh my god i have therapy
tomorrow too we're going to talk about
all of this i think a lot of that though
it does have to do with i grew up a
jehovah's witness so
um there is a lot of guilt in succeeding
especially in the entertainment industry
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
fear involved i'm working through that
actually constantly
i'm working through the mud the murk and
the mud
of growing up uh in a way where i was
supposed to be not part of this world
and i wasn't supposed to buy into any of
it and my whole life was supposed to be
devoted
to the church
so
um i've been out for many years but it's
still back there and i still it still
comes up so
um
and not that my story is totally unique
i think a lot of people have a
have a rough time with it because
especially you know where you come from
working class family and you know it's
my grandfather
uh grandpa duchene i you know he lived a
mile away from me in san francisco in
the last five years of his life i
stopped talking to him because i would
go over there and he'd he would um
insult me for my
choices insult me for writing didn't
understand why i didn't have a union job
like he had
and um
and it was constantly insulting and i
was and i'm like i have enough
of my own self-doubt i don't need to be
put down
so much so i basically cut him off out
of my life
and um and it was
it's sad but i had to do it
because
he wanted me to just be weighed down and
and plus he doesn't understand there's
not
there's not a lot of money coming in
this is this is all an act of faith but
it's also not even an act of faith it's
a um
it's a
it's a half two when you realize you're
a writer
you have to write
and it doesn't matter if anything gets
published and it doesn't matter it's i'm
a crappy person if i'm not actively
writing and in order to not be a crappy
person in this world i'm going to keep
writing and then i'll be nicer to be
around
so
interesting so when you see a student in
one of your classes or a zooms you know
sort of relationship
and you can tell like this person has
some talent it just needs some refining
but i'm seeing they almost they feel
guilty about like they feel like
shameful that they have talent
what do you do to help them sort of
come out of that or you don't you figure
that's their own process you don't want
to rush it
yeah i mean
there's
great talented people that come through
um i'm there i'm there to i'm there to
help them with their craft and i'm there
to give them and to cheerlead them
but at the same time i'm also not their
therapist so if they if they have guilt
if they you know i could come back i can
come in with hey this is what hap this
is what i've worked through and this is
and i usually and this is what a lot of
writers work through i'm i get to you
know i get to interview best-selling
authors all the time
and they always feel like they have
imposter syndrome they can have 22
best-selling books out that blank page
still scares the crap out of them but
the one thing
that they have ahead of the person that
has never written a book is they
remember the 22 best sellers
every blank page scared the crap out of
them and then it went to a best seller
so they know i remember this feeling and
i'm still going to do it uh and i think
that's essentially all writing is
to uh just know that it doesn't feel
good for a while and then it feels good
here and there and then it doesn't feel
good
and it's uh yeah i wish it was sexier
than that but it's not
and you said just jokingly you always
feel shame
writing something why is that ah
was was that a freudian slip um
i don't know if i
i don't always feel shame i just think
that there's just a feeling of um
it's it's a it's a it's the working
class in me it's the working class
family background it's why are my hands
not calloused
and why are my joints not aching at the
end of the day um
where
i've
i've completely ruined the tradition of
the duchenes
i'm not monkey wrenching under a car
um
monkey wrenching with a with a light
felted pen and an illegal paper and you
know you can actually make money and a
living doing this how absurd is this
it's uh
so
maybe maybe my joke was probably more uh
because i was hiding the fact that uh i
i'm
it's not it's just weird to be a writer
in from where i've grown up it's it's
weird to do anything that's not um
mechanical or
you know has has union has a you know
very strong union that
so-called strong union that but i wasn't
sure if you meant to also exposing uh
thoughts and things about yourself that
even if they aren't really that
you know controversial that it's just
you're letting people know your thought
process right so um that shame i kind of
don't have
because my philosophy is if it scares me
it's the right thing so i'll write
things that scare me i'll write things
that i don't want anyone to ever know
about me in my life
and
but when i have that feeling of oh my
god nobody could ever know this that's
when i know i have to write it that's
that's when i know i have to go there
and it's just hilarious that once those
things come out people go
i've i feel that way too uh and and it's
everyone is just like how did you write
that i can never write that but i feel
the exact same way so um
the the beauty of just going to the
scary places i think that's that's what
i
i don't enjoy it but i do it and when
i'm when i'm scared to do it i know i'm
doing something right i know i'm heading
in a good direction